I live where the weather changes during the year.
It changes with each season.
We have four seasons.
We start with spring.
Then comes summer.
Then comes fall.
Then comes winter.
It is spring and the snow melts.
It gets warmer, and plants begin to grow.
The days get longer, and the nights get shorter.
I wear my jacket.
It is summer.
It gets hot, and the plants grow bigger.
The days are long, and the nights are short.
I wear my shorts.
It is fall.
It gets cooler, and the plants stop growing.
The days get shorter, and the nights get longer.
I wear my sweater.
It is winter.
It is cold, and many plants die.
The snow begins to fall, and the days are short.
I wear my coat.
The weather has changed with each season.
It got warmer and warmer.
The days got longer and longer.
Then it got cooler and cooler.
The days got shorter and shorter.
Next, I will see spring again.
The cycle will start all over.